it's me lad hundred locks and I'm
Lincoln greetings of peace to everybody
how are you you come to get some food
for the so you can replete with
everything else but it's not satisfying
the soul money can't buy that happiness
it won't bring you peace not even a
six-pack of peace you can't buy it
bismillah al hamdulillah Salam alaikum
peace be with you greetings of peace to
everybody all around the globe that's
tuning in to the Dean show my next guest
my next guest shake Zia and Dallas
that's where we're at were guests here
in Dallas and we're bringing you our
guests here on the Dean show sake Zia
when he comes back he's silencing the
critics because there's many people
opening their mouths they know nothing
about Islam and it distorted the truth
and you know what he got a little bit
upset and he didn't take out his sword
he took out the pen and he wrote this
book silencing the critics and we're
going to be right back with Sheikh Zia
to discuss this wonderful piece of work
that he put together here on the Dean
show this is the theme the danger
this is the main oh this is the things
is the danger
mrs. within you this is the thing is
fifteen jus this is the things
this is the video please be with you a
seller male karate who said I want to
look shake Xia how are you I'm to look
great I was taking a class time is short
so I'm just get into it sheikh omar
suleiman you don't have good friends
with absolutely had a class refuting the
misconceptions about islam he was using
your book I'm aware of that i was using
your i was i was reading a book it was
part of the curriculum in the cloud
mishkat university ice i got to meet
this brother I gotta meet this [ __ ] it's
a wonderful book and I hamdullah you
make door sincerely to our look we're
doing the show now I'm gonna I said
every Muslim has to have this book
silencing the critics what inspire you
inspired you what motivated you to write
this book well basically like you said
you hear all of these people so called
experts on Islam running their mouths
off on various talk shows on TV and
basically the same things about Islam
which were very very frustrating to me
and out of sheer frustration I just sat
down one day and decided I'm just going
to do it and within six months I had the
book ready and published was this like a
multiple choice either car bomb sword or
machete were or this or these weren't
even options it was here you know what
I'm saying cuz most people think Muslims
get angry and they're blowing people up
there blown themselves up this is not
what islam teaches absolutely not and
you did the right thing absolutely
because the pen some thai is mightier
than was mightier than the sword tell us
a little bit really before we dwell into
the book tell us a little bit about
yourself well i was actually born in
azad kashmir which is on the Pakistani
side the Pakistani side of cush me at a
very young age i moved to england and i
was raised in England primarily I was in
London the southern part of London which
is Croydon people who are familiar with
England are going to be aware that the
Home Office and a lot of very prominent
places are in Croydon as I grew up my
family actually moved to the north of
England in a place called use burry
which is close to leeds bradford in an
area which is called yorkshire west
yorkshire and that's basically where i
grew up after that
and where I did my islamic studies i
memorize the quran i did the island
course which totaled from beginning to
end memorization of quran until the end
of my studies approximately 12 years
after i graduated i was an imam in
England Manchester everybody knows
Manchester United I was there for a year
or so as any mom and then after that I
got the opportunity to come to the
states and since 1995 or the end of 1995
I've been in the United States you got
your PhD also yes I did my PhD at a
place called the Graduate theological
foundation which is an institute
specifically for people who are involved
in a religious theological you know
backgrounds it so you could be Christian
Jewish Muslim whatever religious
background you're from you can advance
your studies through the GTF or graduate
theological foundation and that's where
at my PhD so you wrote on a subject that
you're qualified to write on you
memorized the verbatim word of God the
Quran which is a living miracle for even
those critics of Islam if they come at
it with a sincere heart they'll see that
look you know they put it to the test it
is indeed from the creator of the
heavens on earth and maybe they wouldn't
be writing such stuff and you have
dedicated your life to learning Islam is
that right absolutely do you how do you
feel when you see people such as you
know the people that you listen in your
book you've actually listed some of the
the opponent's the critics of Islam how
do you feel when you when you hear them
aligning and vilifying this beautiful
way of life well it's frustrating to a
point that if you were to read any of
the things that they say on a website it
used to keep me awake at night that's
how frustrating it was so I made it a
point not to go to these websites before
going to sleep because it was that
frustrating and the only way that I
could vent my frustration was basically
to write this book and hopefully people
are benefitting from it and really
seeing through all of the falken smoke
that these people try to create in
blemishing trying to blemish Islam so
tell us what give us an example of some
of the things that you heard and got you
frustrated and then you refuted it to
the correct knowledge well something
that probably all of us have heard
phrases like creeping sharia or stealth
jihad things that you know people are
saying that the muslims are coming in
into the country and they're changing
the system slowly slowly to and the
objective of the muslims is to try to
implement Sharia in the whole of the US
and of course this is nonsense because
being a minority in this country we are
less than 2% of the whole population and
being such a minority it's impossible to
impose something that ninety-eight
percent of the population may not may
not want to implement in their lives and
logically I put into the book this
example that if anybody was to implement
any kind of religious you know religious
religious what you call religious things
into the the government a Christian
Right would have done that a long time
ago Christian Christian symbolism
Christian icons for example the Ten
Commandments even to this day the
Christians have a hard time trying to
get plaques of the Ten Commandment or
pictures of the Ten Commandments into
state or federal courthouses because
there is supposed to be a distinction
between church and state at the state
and federal level so therefore if the
Christians have not been able to
implement any anything religious being a
majority in this country how is it that
a minority of less than two percent are
going to implement Sharia into a country
which is largely against it so these are
the kinds of logical arguments that I
put into the book and of course there
are many many other things things like
honor killings forced marriages FGM
which is you know
female genital mutilation all of these
things are attributed to Islam whereas
they are mostly cultural things which
come from for example FGM comes from
mainly African countries honor killings
that they are not specifically linked to
Islam but other cultures also implement
these kinds of things so all the myths
that are associated with Islam are
basically tackled in this book in this
book silencing the critics and we'll
shake zia PhD we're going to be right
back with more here on the Dean show
come and see what everyone's talking
about as heavy as having LA and ela he
loves but the argument here is that God
out of his loves because in all honesty
if you really wanted to do something
you're going to find the way where
there's a will there's a way absolutely
there are a few problems here why were
people of generations and generations
and generations being told to worship
one God asked that bad for forgiveness
ask him for for salvation seek His mercy
no one else's so he picked up the crime
which is the last and final Testament
the last and final revelation
I was 16 years eight years in active
reserves and eight years act will do but
the bottom line is that I'm an
ophthalmologist I'm specialist in
cataract and refractive surgery on a
medical director of the major I see
these are not God God is the one who
created everything in his universe
that's the one I'm going to worship and
prostrate to how can you go wrong doing
that don't believe it on your out of
this long and I'm in top 10 reasons why
Jesus cannot be God let's get right to
it not begun number ten number ten back
here on the DS show with Sheikh Zia and
tell us do you feel this is just you
know what I sometimes you know perceive
that you know some of these things you
follow the mode of money do you feel
there's big business in bashing Islam
absolutely I can't remember the exact
statistics but I've heard that is as
multi-million dollar industry and
included in this our so called ex
Muslims and which I mentioned actually
in the book a person may be named Wally
Chuba who claims that he used to be a
terrorist then he converted to
Christianity and these people actually
they demand speaking fees of ten
thousand dollars per appearance CNN just
caught him out didn't he absolutely i
mean they've been caught up many many
times but still the gullible people of
america they basically buy into the
whole story of being an ex terrorist and
what they the trick that they have is
hey we were on the inside and we know
what's going on on the inside and so
that adds more credibility to their
story that's why the masses they accept
them and these guys are making millions
of the credibility in the naivety of the
American I Megan I make an example I say
look over there and I take what's in
your part you see you know distracting
people from the bigger issues so let's
get them you know focus on this fake
boogeyman is coming to get you Sharia
and the Muslims and people are all
scared and then bigger events that you
know we should be talking about
are lost and actually I mean if you look
at what happened in France yeah people
were so concerned about the new job and
the burka and they were trying to
implement that into law and behind their
backs a real terrorist got into a Jewish
school and murdered you know so many
people while this whole thing was going
on so instead of focusing on the more
important things of actually catching
terrorists you know people are you know
focusing on these minor issues like the
burka and and things which we deemed to
be very very minor things that we should
not be focused on and like I said people
are sneaking in through the back door
and doing what they do okay let's get
into the book now tell us you know give
us some examples I'm going to throw
something at you and then you can also
tell me what you what is you know
prevalent today that the one of the
misconceptions terrorism okay it's it's
something that you know happen it
started before that I feel that you know
Muslims were looked down upon as they
were after 911 you know do you cover
this in your book this Islam justify
does it condone or does it condemn such
acts as nine I know we'vewe've I mean
it's sad that we got to keep revisiting
these things but people keep revisiting
you cover this this topic in your book
clearly you outline it what Aslam says
you know what's this llama stance how do
you cover this in your book right one of
the very first chapters I actually talk
about is the title is and the book
actually it's the titles are in
quotation marks why don't muslims
condemn terrorism that's the biggest
question that always comes up to all
Muslims at open houses at events in the
media etc so I tackle that by saying all
of the places and the locations that
people have condemned terrorism all the
organizations that have condemned
terrorism and I make it a point to tell
the people that you know when people are
condemning terrorism or Muslims are
condemning terrorism it's not a big
thing for the media to cover because
it's not glamorous okay it's not
dramatic so therefore the media doesn't
want to cover this therefore you don't
get the
all the same imagery that you might get
for example if somebody actually
committed the terrorist attack people
that condemn it because it's not so
dramatic it's not covered by the media
so I have a whole chapter dedicated to
all these organizations all the
quotations given by organizations that
have condemned terrorism and like I said
it's it's all outlined in the book all
in the book tell us now moving along
problem Hamid peace be upon and we know
that he came with the same message as
Jesus Moses Abraham and all the
messengers of God to worship the creator
and not his creation submit to God this
is what Jesus came with he didn't come
with anything different but now people
who know very little about him or
they'll take his teachings and twist it
you know and tried to scare the people
saying he was a warlord he didn't bring
peace he was this in that you cover this
in your book how do you address these
misconceptions well there are a lot of
things that people have written about
the props at all or asylum for example
this issue of what they say is Satya the
fear is you know lying to people and
making them think that you're telling
the truth and what these people who are
against Islam they say is that the
Prophet Muhammad actually encouraged
people to do that which couldn't be
further from the truth and they quote
for example hadith of the prophet of
arson in which he said that if I take an
oath to do something and then I find
something better than that I expiate my
oath and then I basically I expiate my
oath and I break the oath and I do that
thing which is better so they quote this
hadith and they say look here's the
Prophet he's teaching people to lie well
as we know that this is the situation
for example if a person he has said to
his wife I'm never going to talk to you
in my life I swear by Allah I'm never
going to talk to you in my life so this
is the kind of oath that a person should
not be implementing it's a bad earth to
have taken but nevertheless it's an oath
all the same so to get out of this oath
he has to pay the expiration which is to
either feed or clothe 10 4 p
or to set a slave free or too fast for
three continuous days so if he XP eights
for this oath then he can break the oath
and then he is not going to be held
accountable for actually breaking the
earth because he's but you know given
the expiation but what these
Islamophobes say is they just quote the
hadith and say that look His Prophet
Muhammad encouraging his followers to
actually lie so again this is just a
simple example but there are countless
examples of where they quote hadith or I
out of the Quran which mean one thing
but when taken out of context they
basically give the impression that it
has it has a completely different
meaning so we are not people who have a
green light to lie absolutely not not
this is a major sin in Islam yeah
there's only one situation for example
as the koran says allah lemon oakley ha
raham ultima in New Bajema a person puts
a gun to your head and he tells you
denounce Islam so in that situation to
save your life you're allowed to say ok
i denounce islam as long as the heart
itself it is my humble Iman it has a man
in it and you know that in your heart
you still have Iman and by your tongue
you are basically denouncing Islam just
to save your life it is permissible to
do that and that's really the only
situation how about if your wife cook
you some food and she was like upset for
you during the week you now you know you
may put some too much spices in the food
and okay your she says honey haha how
does it taste you're allowed to like
that too okay because that would be
counted as a white light and that's okay
because and even a hadith say that that
to put somebody at ease and to make a
person feel good it is permissible for a
person to lie and and this would be a
classic example of that but now you know
you're conveying the message of Islam
and twisting the truth I mean that's
counterproductive eventually going to
find out what the truth is absolutely if
we as Muslims stand up and proclaim the
truth and propagate the truth then then
inshallah
cannot be cannot be suppressed and I
don't see what there is a lie about the
simple message of Islam is simple
worship the crater not his creation and
obey god that's on his terms was there
to lie about that absolutely we're going
to be right back with more here with
Sheikh Zia on the Dean show hope can you
put your dream home and you've got your
dream car but you're going to get old
and things are going to happen to you in
your life and then what have you got at
the end of the day is an empty dream
that has no real foundation we are gonna
die and we're going to meet our Lord and
he is going to judge us it becomes an
obligation for each single human being
to find out what the Quran is Islam is
telling us to stay away from things
which are bad for your person in bed for
the society it's killing of innocent
human beings human life is precious back
here on a Dean show with the author of
silencing the critics you did it with
the pen not with the sword and thank you
for being with us here on a Dean show to
discuss your book at the end you're
going to let our audience know how they
can get this book alright because I feel
that it's very important that people
have this book they're going to be able
to feel more comfortably going to feel
more comfortable being able to answer
some of these false misconceptions
misrepresentations of Islam you know
using logic and using you know the
wonderful arguments that you bring up so
we don't have to be reactionaries and
just getting emotional and we know
there's lying so sometimes people might
react the wrong way but we need to use
our intelligence right that's why you
wrote the book absolutely okay
continuing on tell us you you go over
verse I just actually finished I read
about eighty percent of the book ninety
percent of the book I just finished it
on the plane over here actually the the
last part of the book you go from aya
from aya in the Quran from verse 2 verse
and all the verses that are talking
about you know combat you where the
people will miss quote them you actually
show okay they take the verse they leave
what's in front and after they they
don't include it they'll quote it out of
context you know talk to us about this
yeah
the one whole section of the book deals
with all those quranic verses basically
what I went to is one of those
anti-islamic websites and I took every
single verse that that website was
talking about critical of Islam and I
took the verse and then I took the
surrounding verses before and after it
and then put the meaning in its correct
context and explained to the people that
what the anti-islamic website is
portraying the violence etc it's not
exactly what it's what it's what they
are saying okay so put into it's correct
context you will find that actually what
Islam is encouraging is not warfare but
it's encouraging people to lean towards
peace to lean towards treaties to try to
avoid warfare to try to avoid fighting
and wherever there is the mention of
fighting you will find that it is
usually in response to people who are
attacking you first so that's if you go
through this whole section I believe
it's like 30 or 40 verses you will find
that you know it's real good ammunition
for a person who's ever been attacked in
this way by having both verses of the
Quran thrown at him you can just look
them up and say look this is what it
actually means so the whole section in
this book deals with that you don't have
to go into it now because we're almost
out of time but just go over some some
some highlights of the book that people
get excited about knowing that okay this
is like I've been wondering how to
answer this question that question you
know what are some of the things that
people can look forward to reading in
the book okay well it talks about
terrorism for example it talks about why
the possible lot of them had multiple
wives this thing about the profs arsenal
this about him marrying a young I've got
a lot done on huh and the arguments
against it the issue cultural issues
which people associate with Islam like
honor killings forced marriages the
concept of the Mattoon you know this is
a very
common word used by these non-muslims
they say that the Muslims want to turn
us into them means what is the concept
of a thin me and what rights do the
thing we have and under an Islamic
government okay so what is exactly the
definition of them like I said the
issues related with terrorism the verses
which were quoted out of context hadith
which were coated out of context the
accusations against the reliability of
the Quran okay all of the things for
example some people they say that the
Topsail Island he copied the Quran from
Christians or Jews and how to deal with
that the issue of some people accusing
Muslims of worshiping a moon god where
did that come from who actually
fabricated his accusation and the answer
to that even from non-muslim sources
there are people who denounced that
belief that is propagated that muslims
worship some kind of moon god all in the
book it's all in the book okay where can
people get the book well the book is
available on either the website
silencing the critics calm you can go
and purchase it directly from there or
if you go to amazon.com it's available
it's also available on the kindle so all
of these three sources are you can get
it from shall are very very soon i'm
coming out with a second edition which
has more information and it's organized
you know in a better structured way so
that second edition will be coming out
soon and hopefully it's going to be
across all forms of electronic
electronic media for example the kindle
the nook i I books etc etc it should be
on that also so that second edition
within the next couple of months to be
released if anybody wants to have
multiple orders contact me at the
islamic center of irving and i can tell
them how to get them at it at a cheaper
discount in charlotte if Fox News CNN
one of these big networks wants to bring
you on and they have some of these
people that are listed in your book the
people that are maligning Islam you are
you up for the go sure why not okay
great so 30 seconds now 30 set we got to
cut out you know for the person has
confused you said you know what I like
to
belief in one guy that's the only
worship the crater not the creation and
that you do good you establish your life
around the commands of God you don't
follow your lesson desire as you work to
please the Creator before you meet him
and all the wonderful teachers of Islam
but he's confused you know what it means
I heard somebody's nonsense this phony
baloney mumbo-jumbo out there what
advice do you have for that person
that's just a little bit you know
confused my advice for that person will
be to go to somebody knowledgeable who
knows about Islam and can basically
answer every single question that he has
one by one and any kind of doubts that
he has they can be they can be quashed
by a person who has the true knowledge
so go to somebody knowledgeable who can
answer your questions and I'm very very
sure that any kind of doubts that you
have they will be eliminated by this
knowledgeable person each other thank
you very much for being with us here and
the Dean show may God Almighty Creator
Allah reward you thank you so much
psychologic oh yeah and that was shaped
zia PhD who wrote the book silencing the
critics had them on the show you got to
get the book it's something that you
should have and definitely you'll be
able to benefit from it thank you for
tuning in make sure that you give us a
call if you have any questions that are
unanswered that we dancer initial 1 800
662 Islam call us we're here operators
are standing by to answer your questions
and if you'd like verbatim word of god
the verbatim would have got for free
call us it's yours all you got to do is
ask and you've come to the right place
continue to turn in here to the Dean
show we're here to help you understand
to develop a better understanding we'll
see you next time until then peace be
with you and if we're going to worship
something I figured I might as well
worship the Creator instead of any of
the creations now in upon investigating
the villages I remember find another
meaning of what Islam is what Muslim is
those who surrender yourself to God is a
Muslim those who surrender submit to God
God's will Daisy Islam was pure it was
just you just pray to God alone if Eliza
I am not afraid to stay I am not afraid
to stand alone I am not afraid of